let's consider a gravitational slingshot
what is that well once in a while people
like to send spacecraft out into the
solar system particularly the outer
solar system to explore what's going on
there and because we can't on earth give
enough speed to these little spacecrafts
we need the big planets around us to
help us a little and so we can consider
a large planet like Jupiter or Saturn
here we have Saturn and if we have a
little spacecraft and we make it fly by
clothes then what actually happens is it
will due to the gravitational attraction
of Saturn acquire a kick in velocity and
that is a gravitational slingshot so
let's look at that so our little
spacecraft comes in with an initial
velocity and Saturn of course also has a
velocity and once it has passed a little
spacecraft will have a final velocity
and in order to calculate what this
final velocity is going to be what the
increase in speed is going to be we need
the concept of relative velocity and for
that we need to first consider some
initial State so we have the relative
velocity initially and that is the
difference between the those two
velocities between the spacecraft and
Saturn and what becomes very important
here is that we look at the coordinate
system and keep that in mind otherwise
we're going to get a few sign errors so
the villa the initial velocity of the
spacecraft goes in the I hat direction
and the velocity the relative velocity
is of course a difference so minus the
velocity of Saturn but that one goes in
the - I hat direction and then we have
the final state
so we final relative and here we have
the final velocity of the spacecraft now
going in the - I had direction - the
velocity of Saturn that also goes in the
- I had direction now there's one thing
that we need to consider which is this
velocity of Saturn this one actually is
of course here the initial velocity of
Saturn and this one is the final one
but because the mass of Saturn is so
much larger than the mass of the
spacecraft we can actually set the
initial velocity of Saturn to the final
velocity of Saturn so we can turn this
we can take this away here again and
just consider one velocity of Saturn
okay good there's one more thing that we
need in order to solve this because we
need to know how the relative velocities
are actually related and the energy
momentum law helps us there because that
gives us that the initial relative
velocity equals minus the final relative
velocity okay so we can plug that in now
what do we have here for the initial
velocity we have VI minus twice gives us
a plus the Saturn velocity and that
equals minus - gives us a plus the final
velocity of the spacecraft and then we
have three minuses here so that gives us
a minus the Saturn velocity and we know
from the the problem that the initial
velocity here of the spacecraft was
actually given at three Saturn
velocities so we can tell you this up
now we have a three we have three plus
one is four and we'll put this over on
the other side that gives us five five
Saturn velocities equals final velocity
so that's a quite a good gain I would
say
and it nicely illustrates why big
planets like Jupiter and Saturn are
really really helpful for the
exploration of the solar system and that
is actually how the New Horizons mission
made it out to Pluto all the way out
there